[Musique]
medenine de plus en plus veut vous
séduire et s'efforce de cacher que c'est
encore la ville de tous les dangers
luis fernando quijano est constamment
menacée il ne peut se déplacer sans ces
deux véhicules blindés le sien avec
comme chauffeur aurait son principal
gardes du corps et un autre s'est collé
derrière une camionnette avec trois
autres gardes à l'affût de la moindre
anomalie dans le trafic de medellin ces
grandes villes est bien moins violente
que tu t'en de pablo escobar mais reste
dangereuse
luis fernando qui préside aux ong de
défense des droits de la personne corpas
deiss a lancé il ya dix ans le site
analyse urbaine qui publie tout ce qui
touche à la violence contre les citoyens
de medellin et du département
d'antioquia ce qui lui vaut beaucoup
d'ennemis
mais les hyènes attire beaucoup de
touristes ville chaleureuse au climat
idéal pleine de charme moderne avec son
métro qui a même fait de la mal famés
commune à tresser une attraction
touristique grâce sans escaliers
mécaniques
tout comme le parions que pablo escobar
a fait construire pour des pauvres on
trouve de tout à medellin est avant tout
de la drogue en marché libre qui
gangrènent plusieurs quartiers de quoi
faire la fête la fête extrême la rumba
doha
la cocaïne fait total et tourisme sexuel
femmes hommes garçons petite fille ou
tous en même temps ceci est un vrai
bordel paul plus grand bordel du monde
nous avait dit luis fernando il ya
quatre ans mais le moins cher
alors qu y at il ici pour la mafia
étrangères et le crime transnational
et souhaitons pas là ici un paradis pour
toutes les mafias du monde d'un oiseau
lempdes canadienne de haut niveau
il y à la puissante mafia mexicaine
d'abord dont il a dénoncé la présence il
ya quatre ans ce qui lui vaut les
menaces actuelles et qui est reconnu
maintenant par les autorités les cartels
de sinaloa et de ralsko nouvelle
génération contrôler la sortie la
cocaïne base par le pacifique
il travaille en concurrence ou parfois
avec des mafias locales le clan du golfe
dont l'extradition du chef othoniel vers
les états unis a provoqué trois jours de
grève armés dans le nord et une
confrontation entre l'armée les
producteurs de coca le ministre de la
défense diego lugano s'est fait filmer
survolant lentilles au kia pour annoncer
la fin proche du clan du golfe
sornettes dit luis fernando non
seulement le clan du golfe se renouvelle
continuellement mais il n'existe pas
vraiment comme tel on a plutôt affaire à
une puissante association de mafia les
autodéfenses gaitan east de colombie
héritière des anciens groupes
paramilitaires
les agc se heurte parfois la mafia
locale la oficina de envigado
littéralement le bureau d'un giga dos un
quartier de medellin favori de pablo
escobar c'est une organisation
mystérieuse du crime infiltré dans tous
les milieux dont on ne connaît pas les
dirigeants
la criminalité imprègne toute la société
des institutions le pouvoir politique
est aussi économique de ce pays
assassinats politiques et terreur en
moins c'est l'héritage de pablo escobar
un costard
un héritage bâti pendant des décennies
incrusté dans l'état colombien
l'économiste philippe et asco confirment
ac
il ya cinq ans la colombie produisait la
moitié de la cocaïne du monde avec le
pérou et la bolivie pour le reste
maintenant elle produit 75 % de la
cocaïne du molosse
de la cocaïne
spécialiste de l'économie du narcotrafic
felipe se base sur des données
officielles
mille deux cent trente tonnes de cocaïne
rapporte plus de 17 milliards de dollars
par an à l'économie de la colombie 6% du
produit intérieur brut et le cese
colombie
cet argent percole dans toutes les
institutions
luis fernando ne sait pas vraiment qui
veut sa peau les mexicains ou les
colombiens qui les protège car il y as
complicité
nous ne savons pas qui est le plus
dangereux pour notre sécurité et celle
de notre famille famille qu'il essaye de
faire sortir du pays le plus vite
possible alors la colombie 1 et anarcho
felipe parce qu'on n'a aucune hésitation
pour un mode de cire caisse
le combattre un défi gigantesque pour le
nouveau président de la colombie
[Musique]